joining us now NRA TV contributor damn
Bungie know Fox News contributor Daniel
Hoffman Fox News national security
strategist dr. Sebastian Gorka we'll
start with you Daniel Hoffman tonight
I interviewed Jose Rodriguez he was
there
I don't like Garin the tape anymore
because I've entered the last two nights
and I look 30 pounds skinnier but in all
seriousness he was there the information
that led to the courier that led to bin
Laden came from that enhanced
interrogation we wouldn't have gotten
bin Laden without those techniques which
were medically supervised at the highest
degree of safety although they didn't
know it right Shawn there's a couple of
points here that I would highlight first
of all it's an uncomfortable truth for
those who didn't support the program and
don't today that yes it actually did
work you can debate the the morals and
the ethics of the program but it did
work we did obtain significant
intelligence not just on finding bin
Laden but other al-qaeda operatives as
well and we stopped threats against our
nation could you imagine if we had these
techniques and they were approved and we
had someone in detention who knew about
a threat and an attack took place
and afterwards postmortem we were asked
if we did all that we could and used all
of our capabilities and we replied that
we did not I think those same
congressmen who are grilling Gena Haspel
would have confronted us over a
dereliction of duty let me go to dr.
Gorka dr. Gorka this is one of the most
important issues that's facing this
country and I look it was the law at the
time also it was under the highest level
of medical supervision
we are not as some of these Democratic
senators suggest we are not the enemy
now they may not have known it was
medically supervised but they didn't
need to know that but and in the
aftermath of 3,000 Americans killed we
needed information about what else might
be coming what dangers exist and I think
she and others did America a great
service here this woman is a patriot at
a 30 year
a veteran of the intelligent
intelligence community personally and
I'm not gonna go into the details I have
some issues in enhanced interrogation
because of the danger it can lead to of
people fabricating information to get
you to stop doing what you're doing to
them but look at the facts we're talking
about three people Shawn we're talking
about interrogations that led to the
saving of lives undoubtedly and the last
point is one of Honor all of these
people were fine with these techniques
and all of these people were fine with
this woman when she was acting director
and never questioned her integrity or
her morals and that is despicable that
these cowards
now do a volte fasts and are attacking
her for exactly the things they approved
of after 9/11 well said
let me damn by Geno Turner other topics
president Trump showed military force
after missiles were fired over Japan and
threats to Guam and even the continental
US president Trump put sanctions on
North Korea President Trump mocked the
North Korean dictator the media the
Democrats said he'd start a nuclear war
what have we had so far we have
concessions we have three Americans home
safely today we never thought we'd see
Kim jong-un crossed the DMZ into the
arms of the South Korean president we
see now the possibility of the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
in total we have seen other concessions
this is an amazing teachable moment for
peace through strength is it not it is
but president Trump will get zero credit
because the you know I got to be careful
and I get really upset Shawn because the
think tankers and the swamp rats
you know these slobs who've been in
power forever who followed these
structured paths of formal diplomacy
they've had their bow ties on they've
had their cocktail lunches they're the
ones laughing at Trump right now despite
the fact that he's got results that none
of them could get they think he's some
kind of a Neanderthal [ __ ] they
followed all the formal paths they
played by all the rules and you know
what Trump did Shawn he came in there he
wasn't used
these rules he was a builder from Queens
and he said wait let me get this
straight there's still nukes on that
Peninsula despite all the smart people
telling us how to get rid of it
he was unpredictable and he's the one
who got results and he won't get an
ounce of credit for it amongst that
class you know what as he said he just
wants to solve the problem which by the
way I remember Winston Churchill said
blood toil tears sweat victory that's
our goal he said the president today
well I want the world safer which then
brings us to the Israelis Daniel Hoffman
they had to strike back you cannot allow
the Iranian forces and mullahs to fire
missiles from Syrian bases into Israel
and not have a massive price to pay you
know the viewers will recall that that
no matter the threat whether it's an
Iraqi nuclear program in the 1980s or a
Syrian nuclear program which Israel
destroyed in 2007 they don't hesitate to
take the threats off the table they've
got exceptionally strong intelligence
capabilities and in this case the
Iranians presented an existential threat
to them from Syria frankly Sean I expect
Israel to continue to mount those sorts
of operations to keep their citizens
safe and let's let's stay a step further
I think the president by withdrawing
from this horrific 150 billion dollar
idiocy of Barack Obama
dr. Gorka is showing the world America's
back America's leading on the world
stage this is a very important message I
think to send the world whether our
European allies like it or not I frankly
don't care they're gonna tow the line
I'm sorry they're gonna moan and moan
but within weeks they will follow our
lead because we are the only leaders out
there that's how it worked for the
twentieth century and that's how it's
gonna work under Donald Trump in the
21st century that's power politics and
the bottom line is very simple you don't
give in to dictators well sir all right
thank you